[Music]
okay everybody i'm
really really so excited today because
bad trip is out on netflix it is
incredible i laughed my ass off and i
get to talk to little rel aka
bud malone from the film so everyone
watching make sure you watch the film
first because we're gonna talk some
spoilers here and then come back
uh little rally how you doing today man
i am doing
pretty good man how are you doing i'm
doing pretty good myself so
i absolutely love this film it felt like
it was like harold and kumar meets
jackass meets dumb and dumber
just like this love child of all that
and
i'm wondering when you took this part
did you hesitate a bit knowing that it
was produced by
uh someone from jackass and eric andre
himself was there some hesitation or
like fear there
no i mean the way it was approaching me
because me and eric are friends so that
that's how he approached it like yo i'm
doing this movie i love you to be in it
blah blah blah
i was like all right cool so it wasn't
hesitancy to do it because i'm a big
outside of eric being my friend i'm a
huge eric andre
fan you know what i mean so like but i
don't know if i
really knew what i was getting into and
i'm gonna use i'm a huge fan of the
prank movies because one of those things
like oh i'd love to do this and you like
okay that was fun
i did it um but it's such an interesting
process
even just to watch it all come together
now it's been like
because it's one of the funniest movies
i've i've seen like even just
i know i'm in it but like it's insane
what we put together
and these are real reactions that's one
thing i always got to reiterate to
people these are
real reactions
yeah so that's what i was wondering too
is like how hard is it
uh in particular think of the scene
where there's this big moment later on
the film where
chris apologized eric andre's character
your character
in the bus and you're saying these like
really good lines because
at the end of the day there's just this
great storyline between them making up
his friends and you changing as a person
but
was that hard to pull off like hitting
it was a heavy dialogue scene for you
and you have all these people who aren't
like in on the the scene right like
these are just
random people was that really difficult
to do
no i mean look i me and eric talk about
this all the time
i dove into bob malone so to make even
to make these pranks work
you literally have to become those
characters and
and you can't think about it you're
literally just you're the characters
because that's the funny part about like
once again when i watch it now
i laugh because i'm like this prank is
just
us talking with our feelings on a bus to
some people that don't know what's going
on
the prank is just us talking loud right
but it's so it but we had to stay in
that and i love watching it because some
of the reactions i didn't see until i
watched the movie because we're doing it
and i'm like damn you like see the girl
about to cry like
you know so it was that was one of those
scenes that was really beautiful
and because that scene and the argument
scene kind of has the same
energy right well we have to sell
whatever the heck
we doing to to draw people because it's
like
with the car crash scene and that
brother like
man we look this dude i don't know if he
was making new friends he just
really was investing like
us calming down and making up he was
really invested it's our friendship
we don't know why but he was yeah and he
had the peace symbol on his necklace
that was it was perfect i was like how
is this even real it's just
like that he's like literally grabbing
us like
once again you know when you're in the
moment of it
i'd even really notice it until i
re-watched it like he was grabbing us
like he does right like
yeah hell yeah hell yeah and no that
that was just brilliant and like
i think what's going to be a lot of
people's favorite scene is the scene of
you guys at the rivermore zoo with this
gorilla
and i'm wondering because i really think
these people that were with you were
like generally terrified did you
have a feeling of like guilt at all or
like am i gonna break like should we
stop like what was your feeling in those
moments
no in that particular say that was one
of the hardest things for me not to
laugh
at because they they were so and that
was our first group
that really made that prank work
and they were so invested into like the
way she grew like they were
when i tell you they were grabbing my i
was trying
not to laugh like i was like okay
fighting that because it was like they
were so invent and there's stuff they
were saying like get out of there
like i was like why did you go back in
it was it was insane
so like that was one of the toughest
things when i tried not to break
actually because i was like yo this is
this is gold man
oh hell yeah and like i speaking of not
trying to break i have to give you props
because i was wondering the scene that
made me think like how the hell is he
not breaking right now is when
tiffany hash's character is yelling at
you on the rooftop towards the end of
the film and she's like
well you smell like [ __ ] and she's right
in your face i'm like how the hell is
little ralph not breaking during her in
this character like you have any tips
for that just for an actor
once again and that's that's a testament
to our chemistry like me and tiff right
you know being right one of my best
friends so like just
it's playing in that scene because even
like you know
you know when you re-watch it it'll be
yellow i want to live right this is
it's just insane
it's hard not to break but once you in
it you in it you know what i mean like
it's just
it's so funny too when you say that like
the break moments for me was like
was this some of the natural reactions
from the people we were pranking
you know it was like right i only felt
bad one time only like with the porta
potty
uh prank those were dates that bud was
uh
so oh my god those are actually dates so
one of the ladies we had it was a really
good date like
bud found he was eating like spaghetti
together it was it was crazy
oh and i felt terrible after like oh
that's a prank like you know
like that i think yeah you're getting
stuck in a porta potty
you still want to talk to me
oh man that's amazing i felt bad that's
the only time i felt bad like damn she
really really okay no that's
hello wow that's a crazy story that's
just blowing my mind right now so
what i'm wondering too is did you guys i
don't know what year you filmed this but
did you guys have any problems at any
points with them recognizing you eric or
tiffany like with someone blowing it
like just a random stranger well
we'll have people like you know like one
time it was a girl
really literally like yo you look like
little real and i'm like hit that all
the time and just kept it moving right i
didn't jump over there i didn't hard
voted and kept it moving but
a lot of times if we saw somebody that
may recognize us we're talking our lives
like
it's like a code word and then somebody
okay and escort that person out or pull
them to the side
uh but yeah it it and but then if you
the pace of the pranks
so if if we everything would be it would
go so
fast that people didn't have time to
process
what was going on you know it wasn't
until like oh my god i typically had it
like it already like so but it would be
like after a long
thing and then we yelled cut and that
that was actually fun to watch too
that people didn't have any idea what
was going especially
at the chicken place they literally had
to eat lunch and then like we doing this
crazy stuff
that's what i love though i love what
you're saying this and they show in the
end credits all those moments because i
think people want to see like oh this is
all real right like that really
confirmed that you guys weren't bsing
which was awesome and
i want to know is i love the moment of
your character in particular
in the electric cowboy bar when you say
the lion we are the only black people in
here
are those type of lines are you imp
improvising those or were those like
certain things you had to hit on the
script
nah that's literally so it's funny you
say that some stuff is but a lot of that
stuff is improv man
okay a lot of his improv and knowing
we understood what the story like it's
so interesting right because there's not
a lot of moves you can get where you
could just improv like we we got the
chance to
yeah we had dialogue we had to stick to
which is so funny too to do dot
to do dialogue in a prank movie it's the
craziest thing
because nobody else knows we're doing a
movie right so it's like let's do
we're talking about certain days like
what are they talking about right why
they
know these key points like what the hell
right right
so to actually do dialogue and nobody
knows that is dialogue it's the it's the
craziest mind what i think about is like
you know that was crazy right
because they didn't know we were filming
this no absolutely
and that's interesting too because like
it's this crazy experience you're having
on set was there any
fail safes for like i know there's a
scene where a guy runs after you guys
with like a knife coming out of a shop
was there like a backup thing around you
guys like just in case
nah so that was the first day
uh we went into the wrong barber shop so
i secured
that was in there i don't know what this
brother was talking about before we came
in now i know you're like man if i ever
see somebody
they fix attacks i'm gonna kill him you
know i don't know what because he was so
angry right
we walked in we were absolute help and
we was really nice about it
he looked like he was looking for a gun
first okay he didn't find a gun so he
grabbed the knife and literally chased
us
it was the rain luckily i secured
right in front of him and i jumped i'm
on the ground to scrape my elbow
that's how scared i feel it was crazy
more than the same part this dude went
from one to murder us to like
oh it's a movie oh no of course
i'm about to kill ya like what you about
to go to jail cause i
jesus man
that's amazing no that wow okay so yeah
then once they hear it's a movie then
they're a whole different
type of person like that i almost killed
y'all man
it's crazy i was gonna murder you
so what i love too and you would mention
how like
you're throwing in little lines here
because there's still dialogue in a
prank movie
and i like you guys had to pay off with
the white chicks joke um
did you how long did it take you to put
that makeup on for
the white chicks character of yourself
it took forever it was one of those
things too i fought two finale
about like man i don't want to do this
you know you know but
it made it made sense for bud if but
is you know it's just it's all about
story bud loves that movie he thinks
it's a real thing that could happen
and we had to do it twice which was even
more uh
my god because we did it the first time
and it was
brilliantly done it was crazy hilarious
the problem is that the
team decided that they wanted us to
perform the thing on stage again in
front of the same people
instead of getting them to sign up and
then once they saw what we were doing it
was like
oh no we're not going to be in this
movie so at first they was down
and then and then so we had to do it all
over again and that i was so
upset about that because i was like fam
let's not do this whatever we got is
what we get
they did not listen to me and we did and
we lost
that group that first group we did in
the front because they were so angry
oh god it was a perfect thing
it was a perfect day but then we did it
again
oh man we had them so uncomfortable man
it was so it was perfect
i can only imagine and i love that
instagram finale because it like hits
and just like
crescendo's on the most uncomfortable
looking scene for you guys which i think
makes the audience love it even more um
but so i absolutely love the film like i
said everyone if you haven't watched
already
just watch it tell your friends about it
it's on netflix today
and before i let you go little rel is
there anything else you'd like to plug
and would you ever do a sequel for this
film
how would i keep me that i mean at first
it was a hard you know
you know because the prank movie thing
and just think about it i don't know how
unless the only way we could do one
it would have to be in some place that
just don't know this exists
so i like you know i mean like that was
impossible to do it again
because that like but that's the only
way you can do i think you have to go
somewhere where like they know they have
no idea about this
movie like some crazy weird small
place where like they go i don't know
why they would be in this place but
that's what we
have to do i like that
so yeah bad trip international will be
the seagull perfect um
little thank you so much for joining me
like i said everyone check out his
newest
film bad trip on netflix out today
uh little i love talking to you and i
hope to talk to you in the future
appreciate you brother thanks man